en septembre tout le monde reprend le
rythme pas d'exception pour la salle
d'exposition de guyancourt qui accueille
les travaux de l'artiste belge pierre
alechinsky c'est une exposition qui n'a
jamais été montré en ile de france ni en
région ni à paris et parce que c'est une
exposition hockey le peintre graveur
dessinateur illustrateur quelle échéance
qui tient bon auquel tient beaucoup
pour la simple et bonne raison que son
travail d'affichiste il le conçoit comme
un vrai travail d'artiste pour lui c'est
une matière à expérimentation plus de 50
ans d'afficheurs tracy en une exposition
110 oeuvres qui aborde l'amour de
l'artiste pour l'imprimerie des
illustrations pour de grands événements
sportifs culturels ou littéraire
certains motifs reviennent comme le
cobra un groupe d'artistes venus de
copenhague bruxelles et amsterdam
la roue de l'imprimerie le volcan sans
oublier quelques lithographies comme une
ouverture et une invitation à la galerie
lelong de paris qui accueille des
dernières oeuvres de l'artiste belge on
vous invite également à venir voir les
venir participer aux visites guidées que
nous proposons une visite guidée qui
aura lieu le samedi 22 septembre à 11
heures visite guidée de cette exposition
par marie houssin qui est chargée des
estampes à la galerie lelong et pour les
plus courageux ont les accompagnera
également à la galerie lelong à paris
pour découvrir donc la nouvelle
exposition d'alechinsky sans oublier le
samedi 29 septembre une collaboration
avec la maison de la poésie une lecture
rencontre avec salah stétié qui est un
poète et écrivain qui a collaboré de
nombreuses fois avec alechinsky et qui
vient faire voilà une lecture dans ce
lieu ici un petit peu particulier
l'univers de l'artiste belge est à
découvrir dans la salle d'exposition de
guyancourt jusqu'au 14 octobre